we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p i got a voicemail from a
caller who is really really mad at me
the caller
of course is listening to the show in
the background which is
almost a requirement for some of these
uh angry phone calls
and they claim i am lying lots of people
voted while dead lots of dead voters and
uh they're just really upset with me
take a listen to this
i'm not sure of david mr shane
lying on television the facts are
absolutely the facts i mean
saying that people don't vote i have two
friends
that have already filled out that first
of all
in a literal sense dead people don't
vote obvious that's not even what we're
talking about is false votes being cast
for dead people
but dead people how is it a fact that
dead people vote if they're dead they
can't vote
people worked and had a notary um sign
it
affidavit they did their grandmother has
been dead for four years and she voted
um and several other people so you're
lying to the public on television
i don't you know i don't you watch this
program but that makes me think you're
either a puppet
right or interested in just false
narratives
right but either way i don't know
somebody should allow somebody to
blatantly lie in television
like this this is sad anyway i
i expected better or at least i
shouldn't um some of these people on
television like yours
like this program right i'm more
interested in hate
than reality right truth will always set
people free
anyway that's what i have to say i just
was watching and i thought this was an
insane statement to make
and there were definitely legal actions
going on yeah i mean listen so so we
have to understand
um this is kind of how they get you they
gesh gallop you and they say
listen there's there's affidavit this is
exactly what the trump campaign did
uh kaylee mckennany holding up all of
these affidavits
affidavits aren't actual proof of
anything um and
when you the the way to analyze claims
of supposedly dead people voting
is you do what the bbc did and the bbc
started with the claim in michigan of
ten thousand dead voters they took a
sample they figured out
um a bunch of those people are alive um
a bunch of those people there's no
reason to think they are dead some of
the dead people voting were sons
voting and the votes due to clerical
errors being credited to their fathers
you know when someone says my friend is
an affidavit about his grandmother
voting
we don't know anything about it it's an
anecdotal claim about one vote
uh and even if true would would be
meaningless in the broader context of
the election but you we've got to be
really careful guys we can't fall for
this stuff
and there's a lot of people out there
that that depend on
um you falling for baseless lies
and uh we've all got to protect
ourselves from that
we have a great bonus show we will talk
about which recounts will happen and
which ones
will will not we will talk about speaker
pelosi round
two and also the fiasco happening in
south dakota with their republican
governor
and coronavirus those stories and
more on today's bonus show grab a
membership
at joinpackman.com and i will see you
then